good evening everyone and i welcome you
to the biomedical data science and drug
discovery program
this four month program has been
designed to take students through a
step-by-step process
of a project based biomedical data
science and computational biology
training
along with mentor support and guidance
by industry and academic experts from
all across the globe this collaborative
program
has been designed for students and
brought to you by prime biotech usa
faba academy india pharma toppers india
and pro biotechnica
india here we have the team from pine
biotech
dr harpreet kaur dr mohit mazumdar and
elia brodsky
dr sujit tangan palivar is the
co-founder of pharma toppers
nito singh is the ceo of pro biotechnica
and from the fab academy we have a panel
of mentors by dr ajit kamath
dr ramesha dr saxena dr
reddy and dr kakur and we are all going
to be meeting them
throughout this one month period and
they will help you
through the sessions and guide you
through this entire training program
so the first part of this four month
training program
is the omex logic genomics for
biomedical data science
and drug discovery which is starting
today and will end
on may 18th we will be combining online
sessions
self-guided study materials and
practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective
in our omics logic programs i would now
like to invite
elia brodsky who is the ceo and
co-founder at buying biotech to talk
more
about this training program so great
thank you very much pepsi
and i'm excited to see all of you
joining today so as
beeps have mentioned my name is elia
brotzky i have been
working with the pine biotech team as
well as our collaborators
at the talbot bioinformatics research
center for now
a few years bringing these programs to a
variety of
settings and as you can see on this
image
we've done workshops at universities
worked with faculty clinicians with
students
really our mission and our vision is to
democratize
bioinformatics meaning we want to make
it much more accessible
much more easy to get into and leverage
in application to a variety of different
types of applications
because what we have found is that so
many times
training is focused on technical
applications
that's one side of the spectrum or it is
very limited
in the scope and so what we wanted to do
is to expand that scope and allow
participants from diverse backgrounds
apply
bioinformatics and big data analysis
skills
to a variety of challenges that they are
interested in
in cancer in neurodegenerative diseases
genetic diseases infectious diseases
agriculture and biotechnology and i
think what's
important is that there is a distinction
between being able to apply
bioinformatics
guided by someone who is an expert in a
very
narrow domain where you get to kind of
see a very narrow perspective on what
the application is
as opposed to understanding the broad
spectrum and being able to decide where
you would like to apply this on your own
and so as a result of this experience we
now have
literally thousands and thousands of
people that have completed such training
and have found that this has provided
them with a unique opportunity to see
bioinformatics applicable directly
to a topic that they might be interested
in and we have now a collection of
different projects that we can point to
that people have completed
and successfully applied bioinformatics
to these big data sets
like the cancer genome atlas like a
variety of different projects on ncbi
with publicly available data
as well as proprietary data that they
have generated
so taking that as a starting point
i do want to mention that this is not
some kind of a unique direction that
only a few people are taking we are
talking about big data and biomedical
research
as both a unique business opportunity
an opportunity for entrepreneurs people
that understand
uh the value of big data analysis to
extract
interesting uh insights from that
and specifically an application to
biology or biological and biomedical
data and and
why is that so i think that one of the
important things
is that the data is continuously growing
and it's growing in volume in complexity
it is growing in diversity diverse types
of data
and a lot of companies that have seen
this
problem have focused on development of
tools have focused on effective ways to
store data
manage data process data analyze it
maybe visualize it
and i think that that is definitely an
important component of this problem
but i think what many have missed is
that at the center
are people and these are diverse types
of people there are technicians
lab students there are going to be
clinicians
researchers faculty so it really
represents
a diverse set of users that have
different backgrounds
different ages different perspectives on
the data and all of them
are important because what we have found
is that it is critical to address this
bioinformatics or big data problem
at all levels of data generation data
analysis and decision making because
you have these people that stand at the
generation side they need to understand
what kind of data needs to be generated
and how to make data
better descriptive for the different
types of analyses that are going to be
performed there
they need to understand how to eliminate
batch effects how to consider
different types of data that represent
the diversity of the experiments that
they design
then there are people that stand at the
middle that have to
integrate and analyze data to present
the data to decision makers and so for
them i think it's important to
understand
not only the technical part of the data
analysis process
but also to understand where's the data
coming from and how is it going to be
utilized
and then finally you have the decision
makers people that are going to be
looking at the data
at the insights that they are provided
with and having to make critical
decisions decisions that might affect
the treatment of
complex diseases or even survival of a
particular patient
they have to make decisions about drug
safety and efficacy
and so i think for them the reason why
bioinformatics is an important part to
understand is because they need to
understand
where did this data come from and what
are the methods that have been used to
analyze and extract the insights that
they're relying on
so what we have focused on is
bioinformatics training for people
that want to understand biology as a
data science
and so what we do is create biological
examples that leverage
data to explain how the data was
generated what are some of the
statistical
and mathematical properties of that data
how the data could be analyzed
effectively
and provide tools that are logical and
intuitive for people to use and
regularly apply
in research projects and so this program
that we are going to be starting
is really focused on these kinds of
topics
and so what i want to speak to you
briefly about is how
there is a growing demand for data
literacy and skills in life sciences
importantly the industry is going to be
looking at research projects that you
can develop that provide you
an opportunity to stand out if you're
planning your career
in life sciences in the industry or in
academia
the way to stand out is to really
develop research projects that you can
demonstrate your understanding and
skills
we will go through some examples of
projects and specific applications
we'll talk today about genomic data
we'll talk about how this program can
help prepare you for a career whether
you're
at the very start of thinking about
where you want to apply these skills or
maybe you are
already trained and you would like to
maybe change your career or maybe even
take that career into a different
direction
and then we want to talk about the
outcomes for completion of this training
as bipz
already mentioned what are you going to
gain as a result of participating in
just
this narrow program about genomics or we
hope that you would consider joining the
full program which is going to span
a much longer time and also you will get
introductions to mentors that are going
to be very important for you to
as you build your network as you
continue to build your network
in this field so let me briefly describe
this first part of this program which is
genomic data analysis so this is based
on a program that we conduct regularly
it's called onyx logic genomics
and here we're going to be focused on
specific applications of genomic data
to the problems that are being solved by
industry and
academia and how it is actually working
what is the data where does it come from
what do you do with it so let's start
with the very basics what is the dna
code
as you know the dna code is a
combination of nucleotides
organized in a long sequence about 3.2
billion
base pairs so what is a base pair as you
can see here
on the screen the base pair is a
connection between
two nucleotides and so we measure
typically the dna
in length of nucleotides or base pairs
and there's over
3.2 billion now this 3.2 billion is
organized in a specific way but when we
analyze this data
what are we looking for one of the
things that we're going to be looking
for
are dna variation and dna variation
means
what are some of these example positions
that we should consider as we think
about
how they affect phenotype how do they
affect the function
protein structure what do they actually
do and the critical technology that
allows us to ask
questions about dna variation is a
technology called next generation
sequencing
now next generation sequencing or second
generation sequencing
is a type of a sequencing technique
that is high throughput and what does it
mean high throughput that means that
dna is largely broken out into
small little short pieces and then we
have to piece those pieces back together
into whatever region we are trying to
analyze
and start asking questions about
variation
that could explain what we are observing
at the phenotypic level
so one of the things that you might
think about are what
is what are some projects where you
could apply
such uh analysis techniques what
could you actually address with some of
these types of
data and so in this program we're going
to be covering
a few different types of examples there
are going to be examples on drug
metabolism
how does dna variation affect
our ability to process
uh drug metabolism so how do we
metabolize these drugs and what kinds of
mutations might interfere
with this metabolism we'll talk about
cancer
and somatic mutations does anyone know
what's the difference between
germline and somatic mutations by the
way
again you can post your answers here in
the chat what are the differences
between
germline and somatic mutations
okay i'll give it a moment anyone can
post their answers
okay so deepak is saying germline can be
inherited
okay excellent and anyone else so what
are somatic mutations
all right so let's uh germline
during embryogenesis okay yes so
germline are the ones that are passed
from parents to their progeny to their
kids
and somatic are the ones that are
acquired as a result
of different processes in cell division
right so after those cells have been
uh okay excellent repson
germline mutation mutation in germ cell
lines like sperm somatic mutation
mutation
any other cells exactly okay and so
somatic mutations are believed to be
some of the primary causes of
cancer even though there are some
germline mutations as well right like
brocco one bracket two
and so we know now that in cancer cells
one of the things that we should be
looking for are not just
any somatic mutations but somatic
mutations in specific
oncogenes and genes that drive the
development of cancer so we're going to
be talking about that we are going to be
talking about germline mutations in
terms of
inheritance of specific properties
that have an effect on phenotype for
example
sickle cell anemia which is a an example
of a project where you will be able to
ask
questions about whether a germline
mutation is present or not and also how
does it affect the specific development
of red blood cells
we'll talk about rare genetic diseases
so in genetic diseases these are
inherited diseases that typically
manifest over time and so you can either
detect them at an early stage and do
preventive therapy or you could address
them at a later stage and you know there
are things that could be done there as
well
and then we'll also talk about mutations
that are not in
human or host cells and they're actually
in pathogens so
parasites bacteria fungi
as well as viruses and so we'll talk
about how these mutations could be
detected how they could be converted to
amino acid changes or the language of
proteins and then how can we actually
map them onto the 3d structures
and so the first thing that we want to
start with as we consider this
is the process of next generation
sequencing
and so the first part of this program
that i think everybody will have to
kind of learn about and appreciate are
the
methods of next generation sequencing
and those
include several different methods that
have to do with data preparation
or how does the biological material get
converted to this digital data that
we're analyzing
and then the major second part of it is
how do we actually
analyze this data now as beeps mentioned
a lot of what we'll do we will do
together in sessions like this
but they really rely on these online
asynchronous resources that you have
access to and you will benefit from
completing before
every session so in every session that
we will talk about
a particular topic we will ask you
questions
about a resource that you have completed
online
in a synchronous way and when you have
completed it you will have some several
different
important things which include
theoretical materials
they include practical exercises some of
those exercises will be
visual and some of those exercises will
be
coding so you will do a little bit of
coding in r and python to really
understand what's behind some of the
methods that we're doing
and then you will also gain access to
projects
so we've already mentioned several of
the project
resources that you have access to but
for those of you that have not
completed the registration yet i want to
mention that
these are the training materials data
analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions for project-based
learning
of bioinformatics and data science that
will be compiled together to provide you
with
a comprehensive in-depth experience
where you will be able to learn
bioinformatics apply it to important
projects
and also showcase some of the projects
that you have completed
as a result of this program so what our
hope is
for those of you that are joining this
program is that you will be able to
identify the connection
between data and the application of that
data analysis to a particular topic
number two you will gain some practical
skills you will be able to do
this process from beginning to the end
you will be able to identify a data set
know what methods to apply to analyze
such data
and then understand the biology that
you're discovering as a result of your
data analysis
as well as knowing how to explain
interpret and present
what you have done to an audience of
people
that are either just like you or actual
experts
in bioinformatics and so to speak a
little bit more
about some of the examples i think we
have assembled a
team of mentors and experts
that will be able to provide you with
excellent advice and feedback
on all aspects of your project and one
of those mentors
is dr harpreet kaur she has
in-depth experience in bioinformatics
she has a phd in bioinformatics and has
extensive experience in cancer genomics
so to speak a little bit about her
background
and how this program will help you
understand genomics
i want to invite dr harpreet kaur and
speak a little bit more about
what she will be presenting in this
program
thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur i have a phd in bioinformatics
specifically focused on liver cancer
in my current role i am curriculum
dweller and research consultant with my
biotech
here i am assisting participants to
learn about
application of the machine learning in
diverse fields
in diverse fields including infectious
diseases and
cancer genomics so recently we have
completed a research project entitled
effect of circulating
uh circulating ama haplotype variant in
ghana on
interaction with our ron
ii for meredith invasion and vaccine
development strategy
in collaboration with uh dr neeta
gansha's team
at naguchi memorial institute for
medical research
ghana using ngs ngsgenomics data we are
looking forward to publish this work in
high impact journal
so beside these recent research projects
to provide
hands-on training to make participants
familiar with the approaches to design
and complete research projects we are
continuously designing different
resource projects
using publicly available data based on
the studies that were published in
high impact journal thus we are con we
have a collection of resource
projects where you can learn how
bioinformatics can be applied using
publicly available genomics data to
drive biological
and clinical meaning in the diverse
fields
now i would like to pass this session to
dr mohit majumdar who will talk about
complete program
hello everyone so my name is mohit
mazumdar
and i have my phd in computational
biology and i've been working on
bioinformatics and bioinformatics
projects for over
12 years now so today we wanted to
discuss and start this four month
intensive research program so the first
phase of this program is
genomics for biomedical uh drug
discovery
so today is our first session and i'm
really happy that many of you have come
up and joined this program
and are now going to participate in this
uh research journey with us
so in this uh process we will also
discuss the
dna sequencing and how analysis of whole
whole genome and exam sequencing data
can be used to find variants
and study association between genotypes
and phenotypes so the next session
is about coding we will also be learning
how we can start from simple coding
lessons in r and python
in in context to understand
bioinformatics and application of
those sequences uh so we'll be learning
about working with sequences we'll be
learning about
how to uh load dna sequences look at rna
sequences protein sequences
and uh that we will be doing through our
coding platform
using uh r and python
so we'll be emailing you all of these
content as you have many of you have
registered and
will be getting the access and all the
tutorials before the session
so that you can also practice it on your
own
and uh work on it while we
go and present it so that you have more
questions to ask
so have so that you have more uh you
know insights
into what we are talking
so after that we will be learning about
sequencing so
what is the history of ngs overview of
dna structure
and the dna variations we'll be
discussing point mutations deletions
duplications
french frame shift uh types of genomic
sequencing what are the different types
of genomic sequencing
so the targeted genomic sequencing or
the whole genome sequencing or the whole
exome
sequencing what are the advancements and
what are the challenges
also we will be learning about the
application in the
field of uh drug designing and discovery
so this will be on 30th of april so we
will have sessions after uh
after a gap of one day so that you can
review the material
and uh one of the aspect of omixlogic
program that i wanted to
mention and i would want you to take a
note of it that we will also be sending
you the recording of the sessions
so which means that uh if you're not
getting time during the time
that we are meeting regularly uh you can
also
do these uh during the weekend when you
have time
so you have to go through the videos and
we will be
sending you sharing you all of that
using
email and also through our slack channel
so i think towards the end uh pipshot
will be showing you the communication
uh ways the way we are communicating
with you
all the time and available and answering
your questions through our slack uh
channel uh which all of you have been
invited to who have joined this program
so after that uh next we will be doing
uh the genomic hands-on so introduction
to genomic
so we will be learning about also what
all other technologies that are there so
microarray
high throughput screening qpcr so what
are the advantages and
about different kind of machines that
are used like
illumina nanopore or back bio
after that it will be about the
application so
biology of genetics uh and how
this is a specialized in the sense
how this has been applied to cancer
research
or precision risk precision oncology
research
so we will be learning about how we can
identify variants and then
how we can do visualization using
integrated
integrative genomic viewer so looking at
the chromosome and then looking at those
genes and then finding those exons and
those mutations
and then it will be about uh projects so
how we can plan
a bioinformatics genomic analysis how we
can do literature review
and how we can start compiling a primary
data set
and then developing an analysis plan so
we will be covering
that and we will be sharing a project
feedback form to you
so that any interest that you have in
genomic data analysis and if you have
any questions that you would want to
work on you will be able to submit that
and
work with our team with that project
proposal
so after this session we will be talking
about
the the application in the sense what
technologies could be used
and how multiple sequence alignment of
these large
uh or viral genomes uh are giving us
insights about the
evolutionary analysis so we will be also
doing phylogenetic recons
reconstruction of those genomic
sequences
and uh and then finding out about the
mutations and the variants
so that the germline and the somatic
mutation that elia discussed and then
uh the practical assignment uh would be
about the
genomic variant analysis and we will be
also using
external tools such as genome browser
so after that after you have an
understanding of how you can do
uh genome analysis uh genomic data
analysis
uh using the t bind for platform then we
will be discussing about
how we can do this in for visualization
and then we will be using filtering
algorithms using other
artwork so this will be a coding lesson
and again we will have coding lessons
along with the live sessions so that you
learn also these coding lessons through
the platform
and we have a very easy to use interface
so we have all sort of students who who
are
doing this analysis coming from high
school
to uh postgraduate and faculty and i
think
they have we have been able to make
uh the platform suitable for all of them
by incorporating
the advanced research aspects as well as
the basic part
so it starts from the basic and you'll
be able to learn how to uh
how to learn uh how to do this uh for
sequence and structural analysis and
then
we will be discussing uh next that what
we will be doing
in the sense of the project and how we
can understand
on uh you know correlate with the
function
so this will be about uh the sessions
sorry this is a wrong date i think uh
we'll we'll have to correct that
so 17th may the program will be
finishing this first part and then we
will be moving
to the second data type which is equally
important and uh
most more is in more use in biomedical
research is the transcriptomics data
so in the second phase of the program we
will be learning about the the second
data type which is to understand
the application of gene expression in
biomedical research
and uh what different kind of
innovations and research has been going
on
so in this uh detailed program about
transcriptomics
we have uh been doing this program for
quite a while now
and have several projects that uh that
uh
that students have been able to finish
and come up with a couple of projects
that you saw
from pooja and uh
and the lara they kind of discuss
different kind of data types so
one of the major data type that we are
here uh kind of going through is the
transcriptomics data type so we'll start
from introduction to transcriptomics
then how we can process data
transcriptomics gene expression data
using different algorithms uh that could
be
uh used uh that flows from one uh
one kind of analysis to another so we
will be learning about preprocessing
we will be learning about how we can map
it to the genome and then generate a
table of expression
and then what kind of uh statistics and
how we can gain insight using machine
learning algorithms and using
um using different kind of regression
and statistical analysis
and then r and python uh into it and
then we can come up with a biological
interpretation so it's a very
a it's a it's a kind of scientific
program that is
being appreciated by the entire
scientific community we have
more than 5 000 user feedbacks
that we have received about this program
and i think it will be much appreciated
once you go through this
so in this towards the end we will be
talking about the components and how all
of this different type of learning that
you're getting
could uh help in a translational
bioinformatics project
so a pharma project for example for drug
discovery so one of the major challenge
when it comes to clinical data
is also the noise so many
uh there are many uh available
observations that are used by clinicians
uh without a meaningful connection to
the actual data
data state so this uh methods that we
use
uh for using machine learning uh
is to be able to do this analysis and
can separate
meaningful measurements from those that
behave in a random way
so we have to identify those so our team
actually work to evaluate them
this measurement system to a disease to
help select
responders to a combination of treatment
so this
symptoms associated with disease state
where separated between those that are
relevant and those that are not relevant
to prescribe drugs so this is an example
of precision medicine
and also how we can find out those
patients or those biomarkers
to help in proper diagnostics so using
this technique
drug impacting the patient condition
could be
identified so plays an important role in
pharmaceutical industry
and also for drug desk discovery and
designing
so that's one of the aspect that i
wanted to tell you about then next we
will be learning about the machine
learning
so this is the phase three so all of you
know that data science has potential to
make an
impact in all kind of operational uh
operational pipelines in a company so it
could be a pharma it could be business
could be academia
so uh so far especially in pharma
the data science has already made a huge
impact
so it's being used now for clinical
trials it's been used for
uh drug discovery so we will be learning
about all of that
in the second phase so this will be an
intensive data science
program where we will be having an
introduction to
data science and algorithms so we will
be discussing about the mathematical
algorithm so dr
sujeeth here who's a data scientist
and one of the leading company is going
to take some of the sessions here
and we'll discuss the application of
data science and then uh we will
also uh our omics logic team will
introduce you to the machine learning
aspects of
ngs data and how we can use ngs data for
different kind of
uh data mining and how we can use r
and python to come up with better
visualization and understanding of the
data that we are looking at
so we'll be learning about pca different
type of
different type of unsupervised machine
learning methods
such as clustering and then we will be
also learning next
about the predictive analysis so that
would be about
uh random forest that would be about
super uh super support vector machines
and then
uh how it could be used in you know
validation so what are the different
validation methods that are there
so five-fold cross-validation and then
how machine learning is used in
production so what are the application
and then there would be an a project
based um session which is scheduled on
july 12th at the same time we will also
be starting
a a parallel program that will run
on kme informatics so machine learning
and chemi informatics
will go on and you will be learning
about the three-dimensional data
so in this entire process uh what we
will be covering is that
uh about omix technology so
to all of you uh maybe who are
not much not uh much aware of the omics
technology and maybe i should pause here
and maybe ask you that
how much how many of uh you here who are
who have joined us have an experience of
working or have some understanding of
the application of omix data in research
projects
so maybe you can write one for
having an experience or two for not
having an experience
so please let me know
okay hi laura so yes
i know that you have experience so uh
and i see a lot of students have not
exposed to that this technology yet so
maybe i can explain this in a few
sentences
so omix technologies are defined as
high throughput biochemical assays that
measure comprehensively and
simultaneously
uh you know molecules of same type from
one biological sample
so for example genomic genomics
is to profile dna transcriptomics is to
measure
transcripts uh proteomics and
metabolomics are to quantify proteins
and metabolites
and so on so this omix notion refers to
the fact that
all that all or nearly all instances of
the targeted
molecular spaces are measured in the
essay
so it's a very powerful technology if we
can uh
give them like if we can have an
integrative uh
understanding and how this data data's
data points are connected
so therefore uh like an holistic view of
the biological system right
so initially omics experiments are used
to
concentrate on one type of essay for
example transcriptomics
and provide uh single omics data
but now uh the technology has progress
to multi-omics
unders by integrating multi-omics data
and uh we also have the platform that
integrates this
multi-omics data to be able to come up
with you know those kind of insights
anyways uh so this would be one of the
aspect and now the next
as i was telling you that that will be
also running at the same time gaming
informatics for biomedical drug
discovery
and have an amazing team with us here
today also
who would be going who will be helping
you going through this uh
this uh training so this training will
involve you know
introduction uh to chemi informatics
which would be structural
structural chemical interactions uh and
databases
and then you will be learning about
virtual screening so how
this can be done in a virtual
environment where you have a defined
protein structure
and then you have a defined active site
and then
how you can screen number of molecules
and maybe make sense of that data that
how
this is useful so uh the next step
after that is to do hit identification
so hit identification is that that once
you have like a list of
good uh binders and you kind of think
that they
they could be good molecules to go on
with that
so then based on those you can again do
a chemical similarity search so that
would be one of the aspect
another aspect is to do qsar
and uh based on the understanding of the
binding site so if you have a model
or if you have a crystal structure so
all of that would be
important so then uh the aspect of you
know finding that
uh great pose uh so that great pose
is in the sense of the structure so like
we do
click pictures with great pose so we
kind of try to find
great pose in docking so when a molecule
is being docked and we would want to
find a better energy state
of that molecule at a bounced bound form
so that we can maybe
uh hypothesize that it could be a good
drug molecule
so from hit to lead modification and
then chemical compound modification
which is rational drug designing
then admit predictions and also we have
dr sujeet so who
who is now working on image
classification so
that he's calling it like computer
vision
so uh that would be also a part of this
uh one of the sessions
and examples of successful and failed uh
drug development
and then data science and ai and
clinical trials so this would be like a
combination
of chemi informatics and data science
and application of kimi informatics in
data science
so this is a very unique uh opportunity
for all of you to learn from this
this uh this part of the program so
yeah so i think uh we kind of discussed
that we will be talk
going through several of these examples
so uh
qrx curaxin is another example so a
cancer drug that is
in clinical trials so yeah we'll be
discussing those in detail
uh during the session and then we have
uh the
as you learned from doctor about malaria
information bioinformatics so we are
working on several projects
so you'll also have opportunity to to do
some of the
research if you are interested in
malaria so overall i think
uh this entire program can help you
learn about different uh different kind
of
diseases uh so biomedical application
after learning about you know what are
different data types can contribute and
how we can connect those data
from from a target discovery to you know
a molecule uh for the for the problem so
the entire
uh entire schema of drug discovery
so uh as i said this summarized my
presentation
and this is what we have planned for you
for this summer
and if you have any questions please
feel free to ask us
and now i will pass it on to bisha
to talk more about how you can make the
most out of this opportunity
and what are all resources that we have
and how can you register for the program
thank you and if you have any questions
please put it in the chat box and i'll
be
able to help you there and answer those
thank you so much dr mohamed so i want
to again
take everybody back once more to the
website
so that we can uh go through the
registration process
and also i want to introduce you to our
slack channel so that you can understand
how
you are going to be using that so i'm
sure by now
uh most of you are already there on the
platform
so if you are not yet creating an
account and setting up an account please
go ahead and do it so that
you can gain access to all of the
courses and start going through them
so please feel free to go through these
courses and one of the
best aspects of going through some of
the courses like r
and python would be this that you do not
have to install
rn python in your computer we have
provided code blocks
right in the web browser so you are
going to be able to use the web browser
to go ahead and do those lessons and
again
if you want to you can go ahead and
download the applications or the
software
and do it in your computer as well so
you have both the options so please feel
free to go through
some of the courses that i have
mentioned earlier
one is introduction to bioinformatics
and on page three you would be finding
the course on genomics which is the
topic of this
entire one month program so please feel
free to go ahead and start with this
all participants who are already
registered for the program
will receive an email from marketing and
find out bio
where you would have your individual
server password
this access will come with 5 terabytes
of space
in the cloud so when you run your
pipelines you will have 5 tb of space
and of course in the upcoming sessions
we are going to be telling you
how to use that and you will be learning
a lot more about how these pipelines
work
so please make sure that you have all of
these access details and
if you have any questions regarding any
of these
resources or you are not able to set up
your account or face an issue please
inform us before the session so that you
are able to follow the mentors
during the session as we go forward and
let me also
show everybody the slack channel so this
is our slack channel on biomedical data
science and drug discovery
we will be posting here for example i
had posted here
the zoom link to join today's session
and we also had many members
join here similarly we'll also be
posting the videos of the session here
will have discussion so please feel free
to
use the resources okay vijay has a very
good question
how long can you use the resources that
are mentioned
so if you are already signed up
for the full four months program
uh we would be you would be having
access
for the entire four month period and in
that
if you have already gone ahead and paid
for an advanced license you would have
30 days more to go ahead and access the
resources so it becomes a five-month
access to resources
now if you are only registered for one
part of the program
say you are only registered for genomics
so you have access
for the next 30 days and after may 18th
if you have an advanced license
you can again access it for 30 more days
so those are some of the licenses
i will be showing you shortly so for the
slab channel this
channel is by invite only for any of the
participants or already in the program
so we will be emailing you
the details of the slack channel only
via
email so only registered participants
will have access to the slack channel
and direct access to mentors for them to
be able to interact with our
team as well as to talk and post any of
their questions and also interact with
each other
and this session is being recorded
as will all of the upcoming sessions so
you will be receiving
links to all of these recorded sessions
so we'll post those links
here as well and we'll also email you
those links so that they are there in
your email inbox
so you do not have to worry about that
do we have any
other questions related to the resources
that we just discussed or whatever
we have covered today uh what we have
covered like
for dr harpreet dr muhammed or elias
park so please post those questions
right now
in the chat box or you can also type in
your question out here
and we will be getting back to you and
now for
any of you who have not yet joined this
program
so we have we still have the
registrations
open for the full session
so if you are joining the full program
all you have to do
is go ahead and get click on get started
and you will be given these
options now as i was mentioning if
someone has chosen the advanced license
they'll have an
additional 30 days so this gives you
ample time to work on your project
so uh what i wanted to tell you is this
that
if you are working on a project then we
have seen that
three months is typically the time that
it takes for some of the projects that
dr mohit
and elia mentioned as well as dr
harpreet showed you during her
presentation so
typically it takes about three months to
have come up and refine those
projects so you have a period of five
months and we'll soon be talking about
how to develop those projects so
it's really beneficial if you have some
more time to work on those projects
and work with the mentors on getting the
feedback
and here i have a question will there be
a disconnect if we enroll only for
phase one and three will i be able to
follow phase three without having to
attend phase two
so these programs are designed in a very
step-by-step manner where we are
introducing you to certain concepts
however
we are giving it an open to you
for all the participants to choose as
they
would want to because many people
wouldn't may not be interested in
genomics but they may be interested
more in transcriptomics or in chemo
informatics
so you can but we'll start each of these
sessions of course with a more
introductory sessions at the start of
each of these programs
and then develop those concepts however
anyone who
has been going through the training for
say the full four months period
would of course have access to more
resources and more time with the mentors
as well as more
sessions that we would be doing so
there may be a disconnect depending on
what you are working on
however if you're just choosing those
individual topics uh it is fine because
we will be covering
genomics starting from today then
transcriptomics then data science and
lastly chemo informatives and i also
wanted to work
everyone through the genomics
registration so if you are just
interested
in registering for the first half of the
program which is starting today
again you have the option here start
from the beginner and we also
have an option for taking 55 percent
off for this entire training so make
sure that you're putting in the coupon
code that has been emailed to you
in this and clicking on apply wait for a
second so that it
shows that that coupon has been accepted
and then you can go ahead and put in
your card details
and if you're paying any of the mentors
please feel free to reach out to them
either faba academy or pro biotechnica
or pharma toppers and you can also reach
out to us marketing at pine dot bio
again for any questions
in regards to the resources and the
training
as well as registration and we will be
happy to help you out